matthieu delormeau voulu mathieu à
l'effet matures alors mathieu qu'est ce
que vous diriez de lui acheter je vous
disais quelque chose sur chacun des
chroniqueurs avant de faire la haye à
l'avenir y est quoi alors je dirais que
mathieu il a fait quoi avant avant de
venir ici lui c'était quoi sa carrière
monsieur vous étiez vous étiez vous
travaillez dans la presse people s'est
pas non non je connais bien les
chroniqueurs alors il faisait quoi avant
lui il était sur quelle chaîne et sur
notre chaîne nrj 12
il est quoi quand l'émission people tv
[Rires]
la mesure que votre époux était bien
mais ça fait dix ans qu'on se connaît
comme la veille 6e
alors tu les aimes bien magnifique bon
c'est vrai tu trouve beau élégant
élégant élégant alors qu'est-ce qu'il a
choisi le prochain james bond eh bien
oui nous prêtons pièce book
à oui je veux monter la borne prévue le
15 août depuis longtemps parce que lui
aurait pas fait mon gadget très bien
peut-être si au contraire un peu fort de
café
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non là sur ces vite si on people le
vendredi va alors mais aujourd'hui par
avait auparavant accueilli les gt qui
collait pas mal réduit les durées
j'étais combien c'était vrai ce qu'on va
faire un featuring non nous avons
préparé un texte et on va faire un
disque il avait fait une fois un disque
avec à oui c'est vrai que c'est vraiment
pourtant ce que je faisais oui j'étais
star un talent j'étais star d'hannah les
et esther d'une falaise un groupe alors
alors qu'est-ce qui va lancer mathieu et
moi moi c'est une sa mère à cash
c'est quoi le même mois caméra cachée
qui n'a jamais eu lieu pour la grande
rade sera les équipes doivent devait
vous grimés pour changer votre visage
c'est ce que tu as choisi mathieu
absolument mes patients n'a jamais eu
lieu parce que l'autre n'a jamais réussi
à la grimace la bbc quand je sais quand
je devais p.geo stamm
ouais ouais en fait on devait me grimer
en fut offert candidate alors on appris
j'ai d'ailleurs l'émission de sophie
davant
non je vous lis énorme 6,6 et non pas
énorme le piège est énorme avec moctar
qui lui vendent une babouche
non non
une très grosse peur car on a payé
sophie davant qui a été formidable et
les chéris donc là je devais être dans
l'émission de cyril féraud que j'aime
beaucoup les gars sur la tête de ma mère
un choix raconte et je mets deux heures
et demie avec une maquilleuse un
coiffeur des gars qui me grimm de ouf et
tout et je dis je dis je avec diego et
moi je lui dis laisse-moi 100 m je veux
voir je faire sans mettre dans la rue
pour voir si les gens me reconnaissent
sur la tête de ma mère je sors de la
voiture frère il ya un gars effet
maintenant je suis guéri mais en fait je
suis arrivé dans la salle avec les
candidats et j'étais comme ça et tout et
tout et tout le monde qui m'aime me voir
et me fait sortir ça qui fait bon allez
c'est bon on prend donc une claque qu'on
se barre ainsi regarder les barques et
merci
[Musique]
là je vais te dire c'est pas des yeux le
problème c'est le tout frère c'est la
même tollé c'est un échec genre comme la
queen la forme du visage mais non il
fallait une grosse barre ici pour
changer la forme du visage lâcher des
meubles chez la même côté les mecs tu
fais pas cammas mais franchement ça ne
sert à rien
regarde là de mars est la même je la
laisse le titre fait deux heures
complexe
[Rires]
la nuit des musées c'est mieux là
[Applaudissements]